You've all seen the bombastic headlines.
"The metaverse is dead."
But is it actually true?
I was certainly alarmed
by the media reporting
on the alleged demise of the industry
in which I'm so involved in.
So I thought I'd check in
on the metaverse,
see how it was doing.
The metaverse is very young, after all,
and we should keep an eye on it.
And what I found was that the metaverse
was very much the same metaverse
as last I checked,
except it had grown
bigger and more impactful.
I saw a place where millions of people
who had been financially excluded
find employment and real
economic opportunities.
I saw a place where participants,
either singly or in groups,
formed complex systems
that very much resembled
the workings of modern
capitalist societies.
I saw a place last year
that generated over 30 billion dollars
of economic activity
and had treasuries maintained
by those same communities
to the tune of 12 billion dollars.
Now, let's put that
a little bit in context.
The metaverse has reserves
just below that of the fiscal
reserves of New Zealand
and greater economic activity
than the GDP of Cyprus,
Iceland and 100 other countries.
The metaverse seems to be doing OK,
but this may not be quite the metaverse
that you're thinking of.
You might be thinking of the metaverse
as this 3D virtual-reality immersive space
with additional sensory stimulation.
No, what I'm talking about
is the open metaverse,
powered by web3 and blockchain.
The treasuries that I'm referring to
are the treasuries of DAOs.
Twelve billion dollars
within control of its communities
without any central authority.
The banking system underlying
the open metaverse is DeFi.
You might have heard
of decentralized finance before,
but you may not have known
that it is part and parcel
of the open metaverse.
All of this open metaverse
is powered by blockchain
and comprises part
of what we describe as web3,
which we firmly believe will be
the future iteration of the internet,
which is currently still mostly
in the web2 stage.
To access the open metaverse,
you don't need fancy VR goggles,
you just need plain old boring 2D screens.
And you can enter a rich,
thriving universe
of capitalist economic societies
that have virtual worlds,
businesses, enterprises, experiences
with millions of digital citizens.
Our lives already have
a very strong virtual component.
In Asia, where I live,
we spend over nine hours a day online.
That is most of our waking hours.
And perhaps for most of us,
just think about what it is you do
the first thing in the morning.
But in this virtual reality,
we are like serfs, toiling
on the lands of medieval lords.
We have no ownership,
no rights to speak of.
Our digital existence can be removed
on any of these platforms
at a moment's notice
without any due process.
Whenever we are online,
we accrue value to networks
that don't belong to us.
We are farmed for our time,
attention and creativity
and in so doing, generate
large quantities of data.
And data is the most
valuable of resources.
For starters, it's powering all of the AI
that we've been hearing so much about.
No data,
no ChatGPT,
no self-driving cars.
The entire foundation of the AI industry
is built on top of our data.
And not just AI.
Every industry covets our data.
Data is the new labor.
And we're not being fairly
compensated for it.
We create it,
but it is exclusively owned
by the publishers and platforms today.
That is a world of web2 we live in today,
but web3 and blockchain can change that
because unlike web2,
we can now finally have
true digital ownership.
Ownership of things gives us
corresponding economic freedoms.
The freedom to transact,
to do with as we please.
It also allows us to partake
in all the network effects
related to the ownership of these things.
Think about all the businesses
that have been created
just because we own things,
such as the cars we have,
houses we live in,
or even the phones.
Ownership also speaks to our identity.
We buy and purchase things
because of what it means to us.
Self expression,
ownership of these things,
such as fashion, jewelry, and yes,
even NFTs.
A lot of people struggle
with web3 and NFTs
because they see the prices
at the higher end of things.
They look at this bored ape and say,
"How can this be more valuable
than this Birkin bag,
which is an actual, real item?"
But people don't buy this Birkin bag
because they want to put stuff in it.
(Laughter)
Ninety-nine percent of its value
is entirely virtual network effects
upheld by the community
of Birkin bag lovers
who find them desirable and valuable.
Its utility is a very distant second.
And this is perhaps true for almost
everything that we purchase
in the real world.
Owning the story,
owning a part of the culture,
being a part of the community
that forms part of our identity
is why we buy things.
The same is true for the open metaverse.
Ownership, identity, culture and community
are far more important
considerations for most of us
than just its utility.
And if this still feels far-fetched
to you, consider this.
Last year,
the video game industry generated
over 100 billion dollars of sales
in virtual goods.
And the fun fact is that all
of the things that they purchased
were predominantly cosmetic
and whimsical in nature.
Skins, trinkets, decorative items.
Things that make
your virtual identities shine.
Just ask your kids what they want
for the next presents.
But everything you purchase
in those worlds in video games today,
we don't own.
That's 100 billion dollars
of rental goods.
NFTs can change that
because now we can
actually own these virtual goods.
When you own an NFT,
such as virtual land in the metaverse,
you become a stakeholder.
You become an owner.
Any time you own an asset in web3,
it represents a stake in that network
that you wish to participate in.
Imagine every time you shared
something on Instagram,
for value you generated,
you would receive
a small stake in the network
that would be that social network.
Think of the open metaverse
as the construction of new economies
and new societies
with a strong foundation
of digital property rights.
This presents us
with a remarkable opportunity
to shift away from this current form
of shareholder capitalism
that has left so many people behind,
to this newer form
of stakeholder capitalism
in which every participant
can now also become an owner.
This, to me,
is what tokenization
and web3 is all about.
That is the meaning of the open metaverse.
Tokenization is perhaps also
the best way in which we can protect
our digital intellectual property rights.
When Getty Images sued
the creators of Stable Diffusion,
they did so because they could tell
that they were using their images
to train their AI models.
But they could only do so
because Stable Diffusion was sloppy.
You could see the Getty Images watermark
all over the generated images.
(Laughter)
Most of us won't be so lucky.
Blockchain can help solve the provenance
of our digital property
and lay the foundation
of protecting our rights.
In this web3 future,
all of us can get to earn and own
a piece of the equity
on these networks
that we construct and grow.
All the data that we generate today ...
should be paying us an income.
And all the other benefits
that property rights may bring.
That is why web3 is so often described
as the internet of ownership.
And ownership has always been
a key pillar to prosperity.
There is a clear correlation
between property rights
and the wealth of nations.
Countries such as Canada and the US
that enjoy strong property rights
have very high GDPs, high wealth,
strong entrepreneurial
and capitalist activities
compared to those countries
that have very low property rights,
that tend to have low GDPs
and also tend to be
the poorest in the world.
Countries with strong property rights
also have correspondingly
much higher freedoms.
True digital property rights
provides us with a chance
to create a fairer,
more inclusive form of capitalism.
One that can still provide
all the incentives
to help entrepreneurship
and innovation flourish,
as capitalism has done
for centuries before.
This can already be seen
in the digital context.
Last year, NFTs generated
over 24 billion dollars of sales.
The majority of that went to the creators
and owners of these NFTs.
Web2 platforms, such as Spotify,
paid only a third of that
to its creators in that same year.
George Washington famously wrote,
"Freedom and property rights
are inseparable.
You can't have one without the other."
The same is true for the virtual realm.
In order to ensure our digital freedom,
that we not be slaves to either platforms
or any of the future AIs,
we must also have true
digital property rights.
Thank you.
(Applause)